secretary pretty patel ms patel great to
have you on this morning to hope you're
well um
of course we we cannot begin our
discussion on the day that the 46th
president of the united states
takes office without discussing events
on the other side of the atlantic
as he leaves office what are your
thoughts
on the tenure of donald trump look first
of all
um i think i was on your program just
two weeks ago actually saying that you
know we have an incredibly strong
relationship
with the united states of america and
our government will always work with
you know the the president and his
incoming team
now in terms of the trump administration
again you know we have worked
very strongly with the outgoing
president's administration on a range of
issues
um and not notwithstanding the fact that
a great deal has happened over
you know his tenure as president um all
sorts of international events he's been
very robust in terms of a particular
posture when it comes to
parts of the world such as the middle
east but quite frankly you know we move
on now there is a new incoming president
our prime minister has rightly so been
in touch with
president-elect biden we've got an
exciting agenda
there's two strong democratic countries
um you know coming together that will be
working together on a range of issues
um as we hold go into this year we're
holding the presidency of the g7
we'll be chairing the u.n security
council we'll be hosting the
cop conference we've got a whole agenda
on climate change so you know for us
it's very much business as usual with a
new team at this very exciting
time with this big handover this you
know change in
power structures bases and politics in
the united states
sure but at least for the next few hours
donald trump
does remain president of the united
states and i wonder you know
is it good that a man who can't be
trusted with his social media accounts
is trusted with the nuclear codes
well look you've i've had said this
before in terms of what we've seen over
recent weeks and the violence that we
saw you know
in washington which thoroughly
unacceptable and the fact of the matter
is now today
is a historic day it's inauguration day
in the united states
it's a moment of change with a new
administration coming in
and as you know you'd expect the british
government the government across the
united kingdom
looks forward to working with um
president joe biden
and his administration on a whole range
of issues
where we have shared interests you know
on the security of our
collective countries the safety and
security of the world but a whole range
of issues you know in terms of
internationalism bilateral relations
multilateralism going forward there's
there's a lot going on in the world
right now i think we could all agree on
that
and it's important that our two nations
come together and show the global
leadership that you know
both the us but the united kingdom will
always step up and do
is joe biden in your opinion better for
america than donald trump
well look there's a change in change in
presidency but
as ever and we can say this as well you
know when administrations change the
world changes
um the direction of travel from
politicians in particular from political
leaders
will always reflect some of the
challenges and changes that we see going
on domestically and
internationally a new political era is
now
starting in america and as i've said
there's a there's a lot to do globally
there really is as well as in the us
um certainly united the united states
you know at the end of the trump
administration and as joe biden takes
over
but also as i've said stepping up to
really confront
and address many of the global
challenges um that we face collectively
and america has an enormous role to play
in terms of global leadership
and we look forward to supporting
america you know on many of those
challenges
a global challenge as much as a domestic
challenge is of course the the the
problem that every country has with
drugs
here in the uk we're going to be getting
a little bit tougher with some
i have to say significant investment
tell us a little bit about it
well that's right um i've made it the
mission of this government over the last
12 months to focus on rolling up county
line drug gangs
and we've seen for far too long drug
drug um
use across the country but actually kids
in particular
being used by these awful gangs to
peddle drugs around the country now
we've had
amazing law enforcement successes over
the last 12 months
with thousands of lines being shut down
criminal actions being taken but also
protecting vulnerable kids that have
been very much
preyed upon and used as part of this
criminal activity
but alongside this work we're now
putting in this is
this health secretary and myself matt
hancock working to put in 148 million
pounds
to really look at this whole issue from
an end-to-end perspective so
while i deal with the law enforcement
side we are now looking at the drug
treatment and the rehabilitation side
because too many
individuals and communities have been
blighted by drug misuse
across the country so we're now putting
in 80 million pounds of investment into
drug use um or drug misuse centers
how we can get treatment into people
that need that help
and support we've got some pilot
projects five pilots across the country
and we're putting in the largest
increase um for drug
treatment in particular for the fifty
first first time in 15 years
so this is very very significant and as
i've said communities have been blighted
for far too long
and this is important and essential work
that we need to do to turn people's
lives around
and it's all part of that agenda could
we please talk about the
the problems that there have been with
the police national computer um
400 000 records including fingerprint
dna arrest records
were apparently wiped at the weekend you
said you had technical staff
working on the issue how much have we
been able to recover
so first of all um let me just clarify
this there has been this is a coding
issue
so in terms of records and retrieving
records
much of this data exists in other
systems as well so
you know there is a lot of technical
work underway right now
how much of that data i can't tell you
how much has been retrieved right now
because it's taking time
because our officials and technicians
here engineers
have had to apply new code to the actual
police national computer system
and could you then tell us how much is
on other databases then how much of the
information we can recommend
because there are a range of other
connected databases so these records
this is very this is complicated because
the code that was applied to wipe
and delete records um is a new code but
we have to do this on a weekly basis so
there is a
multi-system recovery process taking
place right now
and that is taking time so we will
update
parliament and colleagues in parliament
as well and the public
once we know exactly the type of records
that we have that have been retrieved
but i'll be very clear as well if we
have to go back to files
working with our policing and
operational partners to put in manual
uploads that's exactly what we will
um absolutely do but it's important to
say the computer itself is
working and law enforcement agencies and
partners are still able to access the
data
upload files how we retrieve um some of
these files that were deleted
but as i've said there are multiple
records that are held in different
sources
so you know we talk about a figure of
400 000 the actual figure could actually
be a lot less
when when you know please do come on and
and let us know
maybe we will do that but as i said it
will take time because this is the code
initially
it takes time we do need we do need to
talk we do need to talk covert 19 um
just for a second um last week i had the
health secretary on the program
making it crystal clear that there was
absolutely no time frame in place
for the relaxation of lockdowns brandon
lewis yesterday on the program
made similar comments but once again
this morning i go to open the papers
both the sun and the telegraph and
indeed i think the mail as well
all reporting that there is now a
framework in place within government for
the easing of restrictions
starting around about the beginning of
april first
is that true second if you can't answer
that question
why am i reading about it in the papers
again well
first of all um i can't be responsible
for what appears in national newspapers
and speculation
the government represented on the
program this morning no no no
let me just put some context around this
i mean we are at a pivotal stage
i think i've always said this about
coronavirus you know our vaccine rollout
is underway but we have a long way to go
with vaccination
you know we cannot talk about easing
restrictions and measures
um until we are absolutely clear that we
have vaccinated
private groups and obviously much
further but
you can't talk about them publicly but
clearly once again several papers have
been briefed this briefing hasn't been
plucked from thin air
someone in government has done this
whether it's a civil servant a special
adviser or a minister
we don't know but the discussion is
clearly taking place in whitehall yes or
no well well it's right that work always
takes place in terms of the future
recovery post corona virus
um and that work you know it's
multifaceted it's not just about lifting
restrictions
it's also about how we can focus on a
range of challenges and priorities
post coronavirus that work will always
take place
but i should emphasize to your viewers
this morning it is far too early to even
speculate
as to when lockdown measures will be
eased and the restrictions will go
we we are still in a perilous situation
i cannot emphasize that enough
we see that dominic dominic grab on the
sophie ridge program on sunday
mentioned you know the middle of
february literally mentioned the middle
of february that is the point of which
we can start
looking at the case numbers and
considering relaxing and that's the
foreign secretary
well the middle of february is the date
for when we aim to
vaccinate those people in the top four
priority
cohort areas so that is the over 80s and
huge work is taking place on that but in
particular those who are susceptible
to coronavirus and actually becoming
hospitalized and dying from coronavirus
that has always been our mid-february
target with the vaccine
roll out in that program but quite
frankly i mean i will say this again
when i look at you know the incredible
work that's taken place in the nhs right
now
when we still see hospitalization
figures you know now standing at over 38
000 people
um with the number of people still dying
with coronavirus with the number of
hospital admissions still increasing
this is no time to speak about the
relaxation of measures and we're not
going to do that
publicly yet we have a long way to go
which is why you know you see me out
with the police frequently speaking to
the police
talking about the work that we
constantly do around compliance and
enforcement
that work is going to continue because
by doing that we will continue to save
lives
and protect the nhs which is absolutely
imperative right now